Robert Sarver announced Wednesday he's
begun the process of selling off his two
professional basketball teams the NBA's
Phoenix Suns and the wnba's Phoenix
Mercury Sarver who owns about 35 percent
of the sons purchased the team in 2004
for 401 million dollars the sons will
likely fetch at least 2.5 billion
dollars according to sports Bankers
contacted by Forbes a year ago Forbes
valued the Suns at 1.8 billion dollars
18th out of the League's 30 teams Sarver
set his ownership of the teams was no
longer possible after an MBA
investigation found he used racist
language and fostered a hostile work
environment the 10-month MBA
investigation found Sarver used the
m-word on at least three occasions while
quoting others bullied employees and
made sexually charged comments to and
about women the probe was launched after
ESPN published a report last year
detailing the allegations which Sarver
denied at the time
his punishment which required him to
stay away from both teams operations for
a year but didn't require him to sell
either of them was slammed by LeBron
James and other players and officials
while the Sun's Vice chairman John
najafi the team's second largest
shareholder called for Sarver to step
down Sarver said he initially planned to
use the suspension to make amends but
after backlash to his suspension Sarver
realized quote whatever good I have done
or could still do is outweighed by the
things I have said in the past
[Music]
foreign